so I'm gonna talk about calories I get
this question a lot how many calories
should I do on a ketogenic diet first
thing I want to talk about is how much
fat people are carrying around let's
pretend a woman is 140 pounds okay and
she's fit
she has 23 percent body fat she will
have about 32 pounds of fat on her body
and she's carrying just over a hundred
thousand calories of fat someone that's
fit that's a lot of calories to be
carrying around of actual fat if she's
obese
let's she she's thirty nine percent it
could be more and we keep her at 140
pounds she has about 54 pounds of fat
and she's carrying around a little less
than 200,000 calories of fat okay take a
guy who's 170 16 percent body fat he's
fit 27 point 2 pounds of fat and he's
carrying around just under a hundred
thousand calories of fat a thick person
carrying around a lot of fat I'm sorry
potential calories on their body at one
time let's say they're obese at 27
percent body fat they're carrying around
45.9 pounds of fat that's over a hundred
and sixty thousand calories of potential
energy on their body so then you have
something called the basic metabolic
rate that is the number of calories that
you are burning at rest to keep things
working not exercising just at rest
let's say for example yours is 2,000
calories per day so all you have to do
is reduce those calories by 500 calories
per day and because one pound of fat is
3500 calories if we divide that by five
hundred and seven days you will lose one
pound okay just by cutting your calories
now this sounds logical it makes sense
but in reality it doesn't work why
because of these variables okay based on
your age you're gonna have a certain
metabolic rate
let's say you fired is slow it's gonna
be a lot slower let's say you have
insulin resistance or pre-diabetic are
you diabetic that right there is going
to keep your insulin high and keep you
from losing any weight also the amount
of exercise can influence your weight by
about 15 percent stress can inhibit your
ability to lose weight the number of
hours you're sleeping affects whether
you're gonna lose weight or not and just
the speed of your metabolism which
really involves all these things we're
talking about the number of times you
did a diet and more times you've done a
diet the slower the metabolism because
the body will just compensate by just
for the fact that you're eating less and
then we also have the variable of how
these calories influence hormones that
type of calories you're consuming and
this is always ignored by those people
using the calories in calories out
theory and then we have your body
problems if you have an autoimmune
problem or inventory condition or
whatever or that can affect your ability
to lose weight and then we have this
variable right here
especially when you're doing keto
because if you test yourself and you're
in fat burning and you are in fat
burning because you're in deep ketosis
you're like yes but I'm not losing any
weight it could be because the ketones
you're burning or the calories from fat
that you're burning is mostly dietary
and not your own fat reserve so instead
of trying to figure out your calories
that you should start with from the
front end I'm gonna recommend you try
certain things to see what works for you
as far as to discover how many calories
you need and how many times you should
eat so now when you consume a meal at
the end of the meal you can either still
be hungry or you can be satisfied not
overly stuffed or you can be completely
stuffed and uncomfortable okay so this
is where we need to stay right here
satisfied full but not overly
uncomfortable so don't worry about
counting calories just go for this right
here but start here start with Kino
you're reducing your carbohydrates you
are starting to get any ketosis in your
fifteen to fat-burning many people will
lose weight just by starting with this
without doing anything else just by
cutting their carbs mainly men because
women have more estrogen than men but
the point is start here and start
working your way this way if you need to
number 2 remove the snacks so you're
still doing 3 meals a day
just cut the snacks out if that doesn't
work go to two meals a day skip the
breakfast and just do two meals a day
and start squeezing them together this
for many people will work just fine okay
but if it doesn't work just go to the
next level one meal a day it's called oh
man this works for a lot of people over
the age of forty and fifty many people
are doing this with amazing amazing
success they're able to hit their goal
but you have to work up to it that
doesn't work well take it to the next
level one meal every other day because
there are people they are carrying
around a lot of potential energy
remember when we looked at this slide
this person weighed 140 pounds and they
had this much body fat they're carrying
around close to 200,000 calories of fat
well if you're double this weight and
you're 280 pounds you're carrying around
or close to 400,000 calories of fat on
your body and you want to speed things
up you want to get in the fat burning
you're gonna have to do this right here
and this will work for you so this is
just a really simple way of figuring out
how many calories you need based on this
right here and the results of weight
loss with this right here
and you can also enhance things by
adding more exercise more nutrients
better sleep less stress into this
equation so right now I'm actually in
the process of creating a keto
calculator with a lot of these variables
that are added into it it's not going to
be perfect it's gonna be a good guess
but I do want to add some of these
things in there to help people narrow it
down a bit further anyway thanks for
watching and stay tuned for the release
of this calculator
if you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos